congratulations on a very well-deserved  nomination for this film tonight  obviously a lot of people talking about  the fact that it was not included and  recognized in a lot of categories anyway  at the at the Oscars your father's been  pretty outspoken about that and making  some very good points what's your  reaction to well you know you the man  when you not invited to the party and  all they could do is talk about Jews we  feeling good you know we here with those  who celebrate straight out of Compton  and we ready to party  well you know I gotta check my mailbox  it's probably in there we're beyond  blessed to be standing right here  together you know sound like this is our  this is our celebration and the fact  that the fans still love it and we're  here tonight at the SAG Awards that's  what's important